>> Sean: FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
SARA CARTER AND THE HILL'S JOHN
SOLOMON OUT WITH BRAND-NEW
REPORTS DETAILING THE ONGOING
ALLEGATIONS IN THE HOUSE AND
SENATE AS TO WHETHER THE F.B.I.
AGENT, REMEMBER PETER STRZOK
AND OTHER F.B.I. EMPLOYEES MAY
HAVE BEEN RESPONSIBLE FOR MEDIA
LEAKS SURROUNDING THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
JOINING US TO BREAK IT ALL DOWN
ARE THE HILL'S JOHN SOLOMON,
JOHN, WE'LL START WITH YOU.
HAVE ADVANCE KNOWLEDGE OF THIS
THING, OH, THE ARTICLE IS OUT
BUT HIDDEN BEHIND THE PAY WALL
AND THEN IT GETS -- GOES
THROUGH THE WHOLE TONE IS
ANTI-BUREAU.
JUST A TINY BIT FROM US PAGE
REPLIES, THEN THE CF ARTICLE.
ARE THEY NOT REFERENCING THEIR
HOW PROFOUND IS THAT?
>> I DON'T THINK WE KNOW
ENTIRELY.
INVESTIGATORS HAVE A STRONG
SUSPICION THESE TEXT MESSAGES
POINT TO AN OPERATION INSIDE
THE F.B.I. THAT WAS LEAKING
INFORMATION, SPINNING
THERE IS A WHOLE EFFORT WHERE
THE TWO OF THEM ARE TRYING TO
TRACK DOWN THE GREAT REPORTER
FROM "THE NEW YORK TIMES." WHY
ELSE WOULD THEY BE TRYING TO
I READ THROUGH HUNDREDS OF
MESSAGES OVER THE WEEKEND.
I REMEMBER THE MOMENT WHEN
JAMES COMEY IN HIS TESTIMONY
SAID F.B.I. DON'T GIVE A RIP
THINKING ABOUT THESE TWO F.B.I.
AGENTS CARED A LOT ABOUT
POLITICS AND MONITORING THE
MEDIA LIKE THEY WERE A PRESS
OFFICE.
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN SOME
PEOPLE IN THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY, C.I.A. AND ELSEWHERE
ABOUT THEIR RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THE MEDIA.
MY QUESTION FOR THE MOMENT, ONE
OF THE WORST PARTS OF THIS IS
THEY ARE LOOKING UP THE NAMES
REPORTER?
THEY DON'T LIKE HIS REPORTING?
>> WE DON'T KNOW, DO WE?
THESE ARE THE QUESTIONS THAT
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS WANT TO
HAVE ANSWERED AND WHY THEY WANT
TO INTERVIEW STRZOK, THEY WANT
TO INTERVIEW LISA PAGE.
THESE TEXT MESSAGES BETWEEN THE
TWO OF THEM.
YOU ALSO HAVE GENERAL COUNSEL
JAMES BAKER, WHO THEY WANT TO
QUESTION AND ANDREW WISEMAN WHO
IS OVER AT THE DOJ.
>> Sean: ABOUT WHAT PAGE
THE QUESTIONS THEY HAVE
REGARDING THE INSURANCE POLICY
WITH MCCABE.
SO THEY WILL WANT TO QUESTION
ANDREW MCCABE, THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR.
HE WILL BE LEAVING IN MARCH.
>> Sean: A FEW HUNDRED TEXTS
AND SLOW RELEASE TO THESE HOUSE
AND SENATE COMMITTEES.
THEY WILL RECEIVE THOSE SOON.
WE'RE EXPECTING A LOT BY
JANUARY 11th.
>> Sean: YOU SEE THIS TYPE OF
LEAKING.
I HAVE FOLLOWED YOUR COMMENTS
TRUMP/RUSSIA COLLUSION
NARRATIVE IS DYING AND
WITHERING ON A VINE AND NOW
THEY HAVE MOVED INTO A
COLLECTIVE MEDIA BUBBLE.
THIS PRESIDENT, WE HAVE TO GO
TO THE 25th AMENDMENT.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO ALL OF
IT?
>> 25th AMENDMENT IS TOTALLY
IRRELEVANT TO WHAT IS GOING ON.
IT WAS DESIGNED FOR SOMEBODY
WHO HAD A STROKE OR WAS
INVOLVED IN A SERIOUS ACCIDENT
AND WAS INCAPACITATED AND
REQUIRES THE VICE PRESIDENT,
THE CABINET, 2/3 OF EACH HOUSE
OF CONGRESS.
IT'S A FOOL'S ERRAND.
IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO,
THOUGH, NOW THAT THEY COULDN'T
CRIMINALIZE THE POLITICAL
DIFFERENCES THEY'RE TRYING TO
SAY OH MAYBE WE CAN'T GET HIM
ON CRIME BUT WE'LL SHOW THAT HE
HAS MENTAL PROBLEMS, THAT HE IS
DISTURBED.
THE GUY ON CNN TODAY WAS
SUBJECTED TO A NEUROLOGICAL
EXAM.
THAT'S DANGEROUS.
THEY DID THAT IN THE FORMER
SOVIET UNION.
I REPRESENTED SOME DISSIDENTS
IN THE SOVIET UNION SENT TO
MENTAL HOSPITALS.
THEY DID IT IN CHINA AND SOUTH
AFRICA.
I WAS AT HARVARD, ROY WROTE A
BOOK ABOUT BEING COMMITTED TO A
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL.
IT WAS A PERVASIVE WAY THAT TIR
RAN CALL GOVERNMENTS USE THE
POWER OF PSYCHIATRY TO TRY TO
NOT ANSWER THE MERITS.
WE DON'T WANT TO DEBATE THE
MERITS.
HE IS CRAZY.
THE AMERICAN PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION SAID IT IS WRONG
FOR ANY PSYCHIATRIST EVER TO
DIAGNOSE ANYBODY WITHOUT THEM
EXAMINING THEM.
I TAUGHT LAW AND PSYCHIATRY FOR
25 YEARS AT HARVARD AND
CO-EDITED THE TEXTBOOK ON LAW
THE PSYCHIATRY.
DIAGNOSE BASED ON POLITICAL
GROUNDS OR --
EVERYTHING YOU ARE SKUNKS  --
SOMEBODY VOTE AGAINST THEM.
>> I VOTED FOR HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Sean: IT'S THE ONLY THING WE
DISAGREE ON.
YOU ARE DOING IT FROM A
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW PERSPECTIVE
AND THE THREAT TO THE
CONSTITUTION.
THIS IS A CLEAR AND PRESENT
DANGER.
LET ME BRING JOHN AND SARA BACK
IN.
YOU ADD TO THAT WHEN YOU START
SURVEILLING, UNMASKING, YOU
EVERYTHING I HAVE THEY SAID OH,
YOU EITHER AGREE THAT YOU LIED
TO US OR WE'RE GOING AFTER YOUR
>> THAT'S DEFINITELY WHAT I'M
HEARING FROM MY SOURCES.
RIGHT NOW, SEAN, THERE ARE 27
LEAK INVESTIGATIONS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THAT'S TRIPLE WHAT THEY HAD
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS.
GENERAL FLYNN.
THE LEAK, THE CLASSIFIED LEAK
BETWEEN GENERAL FLYNN AND HIS
CONVERSATION.
IT WAS A MAJOR CRIME.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THOSE LEAKS
AND WE ARE ALSO LOOKING AT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL NOW WAITING
ON THAT INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
LEAKING GRAND JURY MINUTES.
JUST LEAKING IS A VIOLATION OF
THEIR RULES BUT IT IS NOT
PROSECUTORS FOR YEARS.
I'VE HAD PROSECUTORS TELL ME
IMPLICITLY IF YOU DON'T PLEAD
YOUR CLIENT GUILTY YOU WILL BE
ABOUT HIM.
>> Sean: DEATH BY A THOUSAND
CUTS.
>> I'M AGAINST IT WHETHER IT'S
LEAKING AGAINST HILLARY CLINTON
OR LEAKING AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
IT'S WRONG, YOU DON'T LEAK.
>> Sean: JOHN SOLOMON, WE ONLY
HAVE A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
THESE AND I'M LIKE WOW.
IF WE ONLY HAVE HUNDREDS AND
THERE ARE THOUSANDS, WHAT'S
NEXT?